wait do you really feel like Filipino
food just belongs in the
trash
unfortunately
yes at a Filipino party and they gave
you a plate of food you don't like
nothing on that plate I like the way
that it goes in the garbage you don't
like pork I don't know why it's done
you've had adobo you've had pan I've
been to all the Ducks all of them you
know what I'll say about Filipino food
it tastes very different from like house
to house so is it Nikki's family that
has bad Filipino food her Grandma makes
garbage all the time you just call it
garbage now and so do her aunts hey come
over to Nina's mom's is it cool if I eat
like
this we're like I'm just ready to go
what do you think Filipino food could
benefit from to be better for you better
ingredients better preparation don't
just throw a bunch of stuff into a bowl
and mix it
up